on peut pas avoir une grande race sera
sans moi j'en à gaza benjamin castaldi
vous n'avez rien tourné
donc vous vous dites qu'elle et mara
sera ce soir bah ouais tu diras sera 10
numéros de téléphone non non ça suffit
alors alors alors benjamin vous avez
raison je ne vais pas donner votre
niveau
mais mais ça va être pire que ta femme
benjamin vous déménagez aujourd'hui on a
des images mais non
et 2 3 4
benjamin valeur ajoutée est sorti major
c'est bien suivi en direct
non la cité cet après midi vous
déménagez aujourd'hui bajaur oui il fait
savoir dans quels coins de la capitale
vous déménagez approximativement
approximativement à la fin sa loi je
suis sa relation non lieu soit pas bien
paris semble beaulieu rioux bonn ouest
et bien benjamin savais que je vous aime
énormément je vais vous le prouver
on va verser les déménageurs bretons
d'ailleurs fait il avait choisi pour
votre déménagement bonne je payais ce
nom mais je vous aime énormément je vous
le dis et benjamins ce soir j'ai décidé
de réaliser votre rêve mohlala en direct
pour la grande race track à 100 c'est
mon frère tu veux même énormément
jusqu'ici toi je te fasse un gros bisou
non je veux rien de toi là y'a rien ça
va être là ne faisait pas dans ma
nouvelle maison
c'est pire non je suis pire que dans
votre nouvelle maison
benjamin vous m'avez dit que vous aviez
toujours rêvé d'habiter au bord de l'eau
donc je me suis occupé du déménagement
benjamin je me suis occupé du
déménagement et benjamins j'ai décidé de
vous faire habiter vous et votre
dulcinée aurore votre femme qu'on aime
énormément et vos cartons bien sûr au
bord de l'eau j'ai un duplex on dit en
direct avec votre nouvelle maison
benjamin ce benjamin regarde jamais
c'est mes affaires j'ai bien roulé a
vraiment fait mal mais en plus vous êtes
au bord de l'eau douce est mis au bord
de la seine lundi dans le salon est-ce
qu'on peut aller dans la chambre s'il
vous plaît je connais dans le maire au
regard des ja qui dans la ligne à qui
ouais y'a qui dans le nid est actif de
choix mais vous êtes au bord de la seine
messi mais qu'il arrivait alors vous
êtes au bord de l'eau où vous êtes au
bord de la scène je vous avais besoin de
la scène qu'on soit synchro bah oui je
vais rentrer maintenant la salle des
acacias
bah vous l'avait rejoint d'autres fans
que tu aussi bien la nouvelle chambre
devait la rejoindre un film drôle de
tête
j'adore la chambre a stoppé ma table
musée lumière combien j'aime cyril si on
sait ce qu'on éclaire et quartier très
bien là bas tu as un truc à dire à ta
femme
mais qu'es tu peux rien pour attendre
les rabbins est ce qu'on peut appeler
les séries c'est vrai est-ce qu'on peut
allumer les séries nord allumé à lui et
à lui mais bien ces ventes à prix
mais là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous